foreign
welcome to the Ramsey Show
thank you very much how can we help
yes uh I'm currently working two jobs to
try to make ends meet however I'm 59
years old and my credit report shows
that I owe 258 thousand dollars in
student loans is there any way I can
make that go away
good Lord
you're 58
I'm 59 59. and what did you study and
when
well actually I have three degrees and
with parents and and students going to
college they make the parents do the
parent Plus loans and pay for them hold
on you said they make them
uh my son wasn't able to get the tuition
for his classes and I had to do Parent
Plus Loans the whole four years for him
yeah or not go to that school yeah okay
so you did yeah so what is your
household income
uh my regular job is like 60 000 a year
I have a mortgage and you got three
degrees in what
uh the first degree was
multi-disciplinary studies criminal
justice and religion the second was a
master's in accounting and then a master
of divinity in Theology and homiletics
so why does a master's in accounting
only make 60 Grand
uh there's a long story about that I
don't think that a master's in
Accounting in this area would get you 60
Grand just so happens the job that I
work at now pays a little bit more
and you're an accounting full-time
no I'm in logistics I'm a logistics
specialist at Volvo trucks I'm extra
confused so we got the Divinity stuff
you're not doing anything with that
we've got accounting you're not doing
anything with that we've moved to
Logistics
well you're using Accounting in
logistics but yeah
oh okay and the multi-disciplinary
criminal justice is not in use
um
okay so well the answer to your question
because these are disturbing numbers at
59 years old
the answer to your question is we have
to make more money
and you have not monetized your
knowledge base very well
um most people with a masters in
accounting make a hundred a hundred and
a quarter a year starting just to get
going you should be able to pass your
CPA uh with a master's in accounting and
you should move into that field and get
up into the six figures that's going to
be mandatory I'm a little lost as to why
your career is so uh under producing
with all of your knowledge base but
whatever the reason for that you need to
do a little soul searching and we need
to move your income way up like
dramatically a matter of fact I'd like
you to be at 120 heading towards 220.
and that would be wonderful and by the
way supply chain generally pays more
than 60k
and Roanoke is Roanoke Virginia is not a
backward town I mean that's a
substantial City
um I think that I don't think there's
anything to do with the areas of study
or the area you live in as much as it
does your attitude towards it
well when I when I tried to apply in the
accounting field our handicap is that
through the college that I went to
Liberty University they they teach you
how to do everything the hard way but
when you go in for a job interview they
want you to know how to do it through
the computer
where previously we had to do it with
two calculators and work it out the hard
way they want you to already have
experience in sap which is just a
plugging into figures and letting the
software do what it's supposed to do
yeah but that's not rocket science
I know and they think it got sakes I can
do it
right and I can't even operate my phone
hardly so yeah I mean
um
yeah sap is a standard you know you
don't do accounting by calculators and
haven't in decades so
um and
the other piece of this is the student
loans there's no way to just make them
go away I mean you can't even bankrupt
these things and if you want to see
stories of that go watch borrowed future
and so there's going to be a
conversation with the kids I don't know
if they're willing to chip in for their
loans even though it's legally on you
I would still see and say hey mama wants
to retire one day and if they make good
money in their careers can they pay some
of this down yeah
um
you're gonna if you do not uh get above
this instead of laying under it
in terms of this being your career where
the career problems are all happening to
you and instead you start happening to
the career
issues and get on top of this and get up
leave the cave kill something and drag
it home the math on this is really
really not going to go well
60 to pay off
258 at 59 that's the called a small
shovel and a very large hole we have to
change your shovel to Hole ratio
mathematically to get you out because
they don't these are not going away
they're not going away
so the way you get rid of them is you
increase your income dramatically and
you keep your lifestyle down at nothing
which it probably already is and then
you just start throwing the difference
at this very very very aggressively so
let's just pretend that over a year or
two of working on this that you got to
let's just be real generous 160 well
that's a hundred above what you're
making now and then you start throwing
100 at 258 you're done in three or four
years because by then it will have grown
some so it's not going to be a straight
line issue so
that's what you're dealing with supply
chain is not a bad field accounting is
not a bad field both are hiring now and
both are computer driven uh and you're
going to learn to operate a computer if
you don't know how if you're going to
win at this so figure out what you've
got to do to get to where you're
happening to your career with this
knowledge base because you've paid a lot
of money for all this knowledge and
you're not getting anything for it
and you need to you need to monetize the
knowledge base that's what it amounts to
so hang on we'll send you a copy of Ken
Coleman's book from paycheck to purpose
I'm also going to sign you up free for
his assessment his career assessment I
want you to take that and let's get
above this thing